Hey guys,
You know in this day and age that
we live in, Christian men need to
stand on God's word and believe in it.
Trust in it more than anything else.
We need men who live by God-confidence
and not self-confidence.
We are in a spiritual battle every day
and you cannot let up for even a second.
You need to put on the armor of God and
fight with truth against all the lies that
are out there in the world.
All the distractions.
And you need to run your race until the end.
To receive the crown of life.
But how can you fight if you don't know the truth?
God's Word?
Do you know His word?
Do you read it?
Do you study it?
Do you live it?
Do you use it as part of the armor of
God to fight back against the devil?